salut romain ça va qu'est ce qui
t'arrive je n'ai pas pu manger ici mais
tu fais ce que tu veux de toute façon tu
veux dire qu'il va pas venir tout noir
incompétent dans un truc de fou et la
maturation jouit d'une mauvaise
réputation
je parle de l'onanisme se masturber soi
même mais parce que pour voler des
dindons c'est socialement acceptable
mais toucher ses propres parties
génitales ses péchés c'est comme ça
c'est bizarre quand on y pense parce que
c'est juste donner du plaisir à
quelqu'un qu'on aime beaucoup et avec
son consentement en plus pourtant on est
d'accord vient de quelqu'un qui est un
branleur vung rô le sait pas vraiment un
compliment et toutes les expressions qui
tourne autour de la pratique solitaire
c'est péjoratif pourtant se masturber ça
contribue à la bonne santé économique du
pays
ça crée même des emplois mais alors d'où
ça vient cette détestation du plaisir
autoproduit morale médiévale dogmes
religieux principe archaïque ils font
régner la terreur sur vos culs glisse
plongée au coeur de la haine de la
masturbation tout prend racine dans des
vieux principes moraux et notamment
religieux selon lesquelles la sexualité
c'est fait pour se reproduire pas pour
prendre du plaisir mais si aujourd'hui
encore c'est à dire au 21ème siècle le
rappelle il ya des rumeurs incroyables
qui courent sur la pratique en solo et
parce que certains scientifiques et
notamment quelques médecins ont
entretenu tout ce grand délire
particulièrement xviiie siècle parmi
bien d'autres on peut citer le docteur
tissot un médecin suisse qui a mené un
combat acharné contre l'autoérotisme
dans son livre l'onanisme dissertation
sur les maladies produite par la
masturbation il décrit des cas insensé
de patients qui seraient devenus malades
sous répit l'éthique ou qui serait mort
de sept trophées du bien
à tous ces braves médecin au service de
la morale on doit des affirmations aussi
terrifiante qu'un fondée
scientifiquement comme par exemple la
masturbation ans ou non c'est pas pareil
ça se passe éventuellement si vous êtes
trop concentré sur votre petite affaire
ça peut vous empêcher d'entendre les
gens arriver dans votre dos mais ça rend
pas sourd ans par hazel une chose ni la
masturbation provoque des problèmes
d'éjaculation précoce
non ça peut même être un très bon moyen
d'apprendre à gérer son excitation et à
contrôler l'éjaculation
or évidemment faut prendre son temps
pour faire ça bien qu elle aime pas le
matin dans la salle de bain en votre go
fast la masturbation rend stérile non
plus bon je vais pas me vois vraiment
pas pourquoi mais chez les hommes non
plus en fait les spermatozoïdes sont
fabriqués en permanence depuis la
puberté jusqu'à la mort quelle que soit
la fréquence de ces accusations on saura
qui voulait faire un bébé vont mieux et
se passer les rapports sexuels de 48
heures pour laisser le temps aux stocks
de se renouveler ne se renouvelle pas
moins bien si vous consommez plus que
d'habitude
c'est même le contraire en fait on en
reparlera plus tard la masturbation a
fait geler le corps et l'esprit nul zéro
ou se moquer après un orgasme qu'ils
soient masturbatoire ou pas d'ailleurs
les endorphines libérées par l'organisme
ça provoque un sentiment de plénitude
d'euphorie relâchement musculaire voir
un petit coup de poing et ses passagers
est évidemment à long terme ça entame ni
vote lorsque unique ni votre volonté ça
colle même plutôt la pêche très simple
si on va en reparler
bon je vais pas mentir il ya quand même
des risques des médecins allemands ont
rapporté le cas d'une jeune fille de 24
ans qui est décédée d'une rupture
d'anévrisme
pendant qu'elle se masturber mais c'est
un cas extrêmement rare qui en
l'occurrence était liée à deux choses la
présence d'un anévrisme c'est à dire un
défaut qui fragilise un vaisseau sanguin
du cerveau et l'augmentation avec le
plaisir de la pression artérielle
dans l'attention si vous voulez ça fait
rompre la mairie mais la rupture
d'anévrisme elle aurait pu être causée
par n'importe quoi d'autre donc pas de
psychose non en réalité le seul risque
avec la masturbation c'est qu'elle se
met à prendre trop de place dans votre
vie sexuelle et même dans votre vie tout
court
et oui à des personnes qui ressentent le
besoin irrépressible de se masturber
plusieurs fois par jour de façon
maladive et parfois ça prend dans des
endroits après produits comme une
quincaillerie par exemple ou dans un
cours de danse de salon
en plus des conséquences sociales voire
judiciaire ce type de trouble ça peut
aussi aboutir à une incapacité totale à
avoir d'autres types de rapports sexuels
avec soi même
mais attention en réalité le problème
c'est pas la masturbation là on a
affaire à de véritables troubles
compulsifs voire à une addiction
est ce qu'il faut c'est en rechercher
les causes pour pouvoir les soigner et
ça c'est chez le psy sa femme ne sont
pas bien là d'une bonne nouvelle van
boven la masturbation prendrait des
fonds pour la vente et les trombes d'eau
à son pays
j'ai bon pour la santé
et on peut la santé donc nous annoncer
qu'il faut souverain de brand alley
puisqu'on n'est plus au xviiie siècle
petit tour d'horizon des bienfaits de
l'autoérotisme la masturbation
c'est un somnifère viau pendant la
masturbation et au moment de l'orgasme
le corps sécrète un certain nombre de
substances et notamment des endorphines
endorphines ça veut dire morphine
endogène c'est un peu comme si le corps
payait sa tournée de morphine et du coup
relâchement après les membres et
organise la masturbation ça déborde
et oui les endorphines toujours et calme
le stress et les douleurs aussi donc par
extension la masturbation ça a des
vertus apaisantes anxiolytiques et
antalgique tout ça sans ordonnance sans
effets secondaires et sans trou de la
sécu allez donc jeter ses boîtes de
médicaments et eau bouillie la
masturbation
c'est bon pour le coeur la répétition
des mouvements plus disons l'émotion ça
accélère le rythme cardiaque donc ça
fait travailler le coeur au même titre
qu'une activité physique modérée comme
la marche rapide par exemple
d'ailleurs en cas de maladies
cardiovasculaires après un accident
comme un infarctus par exemple on peut
reprendre une activité sexuelle normale
à condition d'y aller progressivement et
dans ces cas là aussi la masturbation ça
peut aider
parce qu'au début pour réapprendre à se
gérer c'est quand même plus facile
d'être tout seul c'est la rééducation si
vous voulez bonjour je suis jean michel
le kiné c'est donc elle a des problèmes
cardiaques
ok on s'y met
la masturbation c'est bon pour la
prostate une étude de l'université de
boston menait sur trente deux mille
hommes a démontré que ce qui évacue le
plus au moins de risques de développer
un cancer de la prostate
pourtant qu'on est coté bourse tout à
l'heure je vous ai dit la masturbation
ça rendait pas stérile
il ya une étude australienne cette fois
qui suggère que si on renouvelle
régulièrement ses stocks
ça améliore la qualité et la mobilité
des spermatozoïdes
attention pour être honnête la majorité
ses bienfaits sont attribuables à
l'orgasme et passe directement à la
masturbation mais avoué que même si on
préfère prendre du plaisir à 2 s'offrir
un petit orgasme à soi même pour toutes
les bonnes raisons qu'on vient de voir
parfois c'est plus pratique parce que
quand c'est bon moment on est toujours
dispo on est toujours d'accord et on
sait comment faire ça bien mais d'abord
et avant tout la masturbation c'est un
très bon moyen de découvrir son corps
toulouse c'est aussi un très bon moyen
d'explorer ses sensations d'apprivoiser
tout ça et devenir un adulte épanoui
sexuellement
en plus de donner un petit peu de viande
est gratuit c'est pour ça qu'on le fait
tous et à tous les stades de notre vie
de la naissance au grand âge en passant
par l'adolescence hockey surtout à
l'adolescence
mais pas seulement les adolescents parce
que du côté des adultes 95 % des hommes
et 89 % des femmes reconnaissent avoir
recours à la pratique du plaisir
solitaire
tout le monde se masturbe même les
animaux
voyez bien que c'est naturel l'été c'est
fini pour aujourd'hui rendez vous la
semaine prochaine pour une nouvelle
vidéo
merci à toutes et à tous aussi nombreux
à me suivre à m'envoyer des messages
continuer abonnez vous ébranlée et
porter minutes
[Musique]